[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans votre 7,8 week end voici les titres
de ce vendredi 25 juin
justement ce vendredi 25 juin le
ministre de l'intérieur gérald darmanin
s'est rendu dans la commune de houille
la ville a été touché en début de
semaine par de violents orages qui ont
causé des inondations 300 foyers avaient
été privés d'électricité
l'état de catastrophe naturelle avait
également été demandée par le maire et
la députée de la circonscription ce
week-end top départ de la plus célèbre
des courses cyclistes ce samedi 26 juin
c'est le début du tour de france
rencontre avec sandra amour passionné
salariés de l'entreprise domitys qui
fera son premier tour en tant que
caravanières notre invité à ce sujet
thierry fabre président du vélo-club
elancourt saint quentin en yvelines
côté loisirs enfants cette semaine avec
cellier agathe son goût nous irons au
jardin de montorgueil à la bergerie
nationale de rambouillet pour tester le
parcours pieds nus également retour sur
le spectacle la voie de l'écuyer aux
grandes écuries de versailles
mais juste avant cela un centre de
vaccination éphémère va ouvrir ses
portes à carrières sous poissy à partir
de mardi 29 juin prochain et ce jusqu'au
1er juillet il se tiendra au pôle michel
colucci de 9 heures à 17 heures les
personnes venant pour une première
injection peuvent s'y rendre sans rendez
vous pour la deuxième dose
un rendez-vous est nécessaire un
dépistage par test antigénique sera
également possible sur demande
les mineurs doivent évidemment être
accompagnés d'un adulte et pour plus
d'information vous pouvez contacter le
point info santé dont le numéro est
affichée en bas de votre écran ainsi que
la mairie de carrières sous poissy
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme je vous le disais en titre le
ministre de l'intérieur gérald darmanin
s'est rendu à oui ce vendredi 25 juin au
matin il est venu constater les dégâts
des violents orages du début de semaine
dernière qui avait provoqué des
inondations 300 foyers avaient notamment
été privés d'électricité
les élus locaux ont demandé à ce que
soit reconnu l'état de catastrophe
naturelle ont fait leur retour sur ce
déplacement avec astrid bergère trois
jours après les inondations qui ont
touché la commune de oui le ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin s'est rendu
sur place
il a échangé avec les forces de secours
mobilisés ce jour là on a répondu
présent
on a fait des sauvetages on a aidé les
gens à on a fait au mieux en a plus
et on a répondu à l'appel des habitants
de toute la commune étaient touchées par
les inondations
la mairie les commerçants et des
riverains demandent maintenant la
reconnaissance de l'état de catastrophe
naturelle
mardi donc la réunion de la commission
ce fait il ya plusieurs ministères
autour de la table évidemment le
ministère de l'intérieur
mais d'autres ministères concernés comme
celui de la transition et écologique
sain bref l'agriculture bien sûr et sur
des dossiers sur des critères qui sont
bien établis nous décrétons par un
décret que je propose à reprendre
ministre président de la république et
des catastrophes naturelles
j'ai toute confiance que la commune de
beaux mecs et communes du sud de l'aisne
la commune douillet d'autres communes
des yvelines d'ailleurs seront retenus
le ministre a également rencontré
certains habitants du quartier tonkin
l'un des plus touchés les riverains ont
fait part de leur désarroi et de leurs
besoins
gérald un anar était accompagné de la
députée du territoire je pense que
c'était important que le ministre vienne
voir l'étendue des dégâts viennent
saluer aussi les forces qui étaient
intervenus parce qu'elles ont fait à peu
près 500 interventions il ya une dame
dont la vie a pu être sauvé la
protection civile a beaucoup aidés aussi
au pompage des maisons et puis malgré
tout crois que les habitants étaient
très traumatisés par cet événement et
c'est toujours bien que le politique
viennent à leur rencontre pour les
écouter et pour aussi prendre conscience
que c'est pas seulement du matériel
c'est aussi beaucoup d'émotion la mairie
et la communauté d'agglomération vont
maintenant réfléchir conjointement à des
aménagements possibles pour éviter
d'autres inondations
autre actualité ce samedi 26 juin c'est
le départ du tour de france 2021 pour en
parler nous accueillons thierry fabre
bonsoir bonsoir
alors vous êtes président du vélo club à
elancourt saint quentin en yvelines et
vous avez même fait partie de la grande
famille des caravaniers sur le tour de
france l'an passé alors 700 huitième
grande boucle va donc se lancer de brest
ce samedi
184 coureurs seront en compétition
le tour de france mettra également une
nouvelle fois à l'honneur le département
des yvelines puisqu'il fera une étape à
chatou avant de rejoindre la capitale
paris pour le finish
thierry fabre et quel impact à cette
course cycliste sur justement le
cyclisme dans les yvelines
déjà pour pour tous en commençant par
les adhérents de mon club qui ne vous
sert avec ça fait rêver nos enfants de
l'école de vélo c'est sûr que c'est un
monument un mondial du cyclisme et pour
tous les événements et les saint
quentinois c'est tout en actant le
passage du tour de france surtout de
loin de la dernière et a joué les
dernières tables je fais pas fait sur
côté de saint cyr l'école
versailles-saint-quentin tellement -
comme celle que tout le monde attend on
dit souvent que les yvelines sont une
terre de vélo
est ce que c'est le cas est ce que vous
le ressentez vous en tant que cycliste
local et puis président d'un club
ah oui parce que la politique de l'ue
consulté par contre elle est celle de 50
ans les greens de monsieur france ok
orienté sur le sujet fait que l'on met
dans la commune d'el en cours on a une
chance dans les unions d'avoir c'était
un terrain qui aiment le cyclisme avec
des gens passionnés et des élus pas
tienne et vous êtes vous même passionné
de vélo c'est bien ça oui ça fait déjà
10 ans je suis un président du basket
qui nous serrent et bombe lui dont
l'appartenance à mon club donc je serai
coopération côté du cyclisme journée à
des choses en france
objet qui ont lu à epinal donc
effectivement comme dc comme la potion
magique un rat je baigne dedans depuis
tout petit quoi alors cette édition du
tour de france pour y revenir marquera
le retour de la traditionnelle caravane
en 2020 il y avait moins de 100
véhicules pour cause de crise sanitaire
on le comprend bien
et le public était évidemment aussi
moins nombreux il y en aura plus de 150
véhicules cette année c'est le retour un
peu de la grande boucle comme on la
connaît
dans sa forme initiale dans son ambiance
je le rappelle thierry fabre vous avez
fait partie des caravaniers du tour 2020
juste avant de nous parler de votre
expérience en tant que caravaniers on va
écouter et sandra une habitante de
maurepas et employé au sein de
l'entreprise domitys elle fera à son
premier tour en tant que caravanières on
l'écouté
[Musique]
j'ai eu l'occasion de dial et il ya deux
ans en tant qu'accompagnatrice pour des
clients deux années de suite d'ailleurs
ça m'a donné envie de répondre présente
cette année c'est un pour faire cette
aventure humaine au sein de l'entreprise
qui reste quand même privilégié pour
nous en tant que salarié d'habitude je
travaille dans dans les bureaux fin donc
là ça va me permettre de faire un petit
peu la route avec avec l'entreprise
l'accompagner durant ses différentes
étapes 1 c'est un challenge personnel
c'est voilà l'échangé avec les gens avec
des collègues que je voit pas
habituellement parce qu'ils sont sur
d'autres sites
donc voilà c'est une expérience que j'ai
envie de vivre dans l'envers du décor
j'en attends de ressortir avec avec
autant de joie que j'en ai avant de
partir de pouvoir participer de pouvoir
faire toutes ces étapes à bord d'un
véhicule de l'entreprise de mettre en
avant sa société de partager avec avec
des personnes extérieures ou en interne
avec l'entreprise revenons à vous
maintenant thierry fabre vous êtes
toujours avec nous qu'est ce que vous en
avez pensé à vous de votre expérience de
caravaniers justement c'est
extraordinaire parce que moi je les paie
très cher confie de france et là on
s'est aperçu que mais beaucoup
d'engouement d'autres professions ont
été vraiment aimé
j'aimerais conseillons de si tu étais à
donner une syncope toujours quand on
doit penser à 40
surtout il faut bien rester on est resté
au bord des trottoirs en général les
gens en épatant versus ne pas aller
devant les noirs des véhicules ramassis
l'église on se paye à une maman de
risque qui peut être cette fête c'est
peut-être populaire ben non ça sera un
grand moment convivial des règles en
effet importantes a rappelé surtout
quand il ya beaucoup de public sur les
bords de route
alors on va parler également des
coureurs de ces tours de france 2000 21
est une matheuse notamment 10 à suivre
j'en cite quelques impôts gas charreaux
djich ou encore van erp tu es ce que
vous avez votre petite préférence si
rivard est ce que vous avez aussi un
pronostic pour cette fin de course je
pense qu'il est fier cette émission
il ya peu les orientations si sûr que ça
un peu vrai mais ça se gagnera dans la
dernière semaine ont pour donner un nom
de favori mon favori
je venais pas avancer parce que c'est
une course de trois semaines
il y aura beaucoup de rebondissements
mais par contre il fera observer
l'attitude de nos français sont les
ports et docks trois premiers résultats
en bretelles ça c'est important
mais le reste qui je vais jouer dans la
neige
et vous y croyez peut-être à une
victoire des français cette année en
france et qui gagne le tour peut-être
alaphilippe une énorme encore quelque
chose encore un peu il est passé
montagneux mais
je pense je pense pas cette année qu'un
français puisse gagnent autour tout en
croisant les doigts ça serait bien mais
pense que ça va être difficile
dernière question thierry phare le tour
je le rappelle passera dans les yvelines
comme chaque année notamment par chatou
avant de finir sa course à paris est-ce
que vous irez sur le bord de la route en
tant que fervent passionné de vélo et de
cyclisme alors si tout est bien prévu
quand on a annoncé mois avant la
dernière étape de ce que j'ai été invité
par la quinzaine des pompiers donc la
dernière un amendement avec nos
collègues contre des tchèques nous les
chansons
eh bien on vous souhaite de bien
profiter de ce tour de france en tout
cas 2021 merci thierry fabre d'avoir été
avec nous pour ce 7,8 week end m et
après une semaine bien chargée et quoi
de mieux que de se détendre justement le
week end s'il ya gars de son go comme
chaque vendredi vous propose ses idées
sorties et loisirs
cette semaine nous allons au jardin de
mon orgueil qui se situe à la bergerie
nationale de rambouillet après deux ans
d'aménagement deux journées
d'inauguration sont proposés samedi 26
et dimanche 27 juin
au programme des ateliers et des
concerts et des animations comme le
parcours pieds nus que nous avons testé
avec justin brasier en avant première
pour vous nous sommes au jardin de
montorgueil à la bergerie nationale de
rambouillet en compagnie de frédérick
dedieu bonjour bonjour vous êtes le
responsable des animations à la bergerie
alors donc le public va pouvoir venir
gratuitement durant ce week-end ces deux
jours donc consacrée à l'ouverture de ce
jardin est ce que des visites sont
proposées
donc c'est effectivement le week-end
d'ouverture après deux ans de travaux
donc effectivement tout est gratuit ce
week-end il ya vraiment de quoi
s'occuper pour toute la famille
des animations pour les enfants les ados
les adultes et une belle programmation
culturelle de 14h45 à 18 heures avec
différents groupes
[Musique]
si je suis pieds nus c'est normal je me
trouve au jardin de montorgueil à la
bergerie nationale de rambouillet ici un
parcours pieds nus 200 m est proposé
nous allons retrouver le responsable des
animations de la bergerie nationale
alors je me trouve sur le premier
élément de parcours la cause de cacao
est-ce que vous pouvez nous présenter un
peu justement ce parcours effectivement
donc là c'est la première case qui est
donc composé de cause de cacao et l'idée
c'est de faire un parcours qui dure qui
peut durer une demi-heure sur 500 m et
de présenter principalement tout ce
qu'on peut utiliser pour faire le
paillage dans un jardin donc
l'originalité c'est finalement de marché
dans ce qu'on peut utiliser pour faire
du jardinage écologique d'accord bah je
vais commencer
c'est parti c'est parti a alors là
picotte peut-être oui la pique est un
polar n'est sûr ça s'appelle de l'herbe
à éléphant s'appelle de miscanthus c'est
ce qu'on ne peut utiliser pour numériser
les formes et donc moins ici on s'en
sert pour le paillage
[Musique]
attention c'est une sensation plus à
bien que les copains de tout à l'heure
alors la laine de mouton boucliers ces
deux effectivement de montrer au public
tout ce qu'on peut potentiellement
utilisé dans son jardin c'étaient des
choses très simples qu'on peut refaire
dans son jardin donc effectivement le
paillage mais aussi la valorisation vous
allez voir sur ce parcours il ya la
valorisation des branches des feuilles
des cailloux qui qui ont tous un rôle
finalement pour préserver la
biodiversité animale est aussi végétal
mais superbe on va continuer le parcours
alors oui donc ce parcours c'est jusqu'à
quand vous pourrez y accéder
donc l'idée c'est d'ouvrir d'avril du
premier jour des vacances d'avril à la
fin des vacances d'octobre donc c'est
sur six mois forcément en hiver ça sera
peut-être un peu un peu un peu compliqué
et donc on ouvre là finalement dans
quelques jours très bien il va merci
beaucoup
frédéric drieu pour toutes ces
explications merci à vous et puis ben
moi je vais continuer le parcours tout
seul
[Musique]
alors je me trouve dans la partie bois
ici plusieurs obstacles à franchir dont
la planche à bascule
[Musique]
voilà j'ai fini le parcours j'ai marché
sur différentes textures le bois la
laine le sable c'était plutôt amusant
en tout cas si vous voulez comme moi
faire ce parcours rendez vous ce week
end
sortons à présence du jardin et allons
aux écuries l'académie équestre
présentent l'opus 21 de son spectacle la
voie de l'écuyer aux grandes écuries de
versailles la promotion 100% féminine
des cuillères de cette année revisite
les tableaux emblématiques de l'académie
un reportage de nicolas landry et
bérangère broye
[Musique]
les danses du dressage ou de l'escrim
avec les chevaux le spectacle la voie de
l'écuyer chorégraphié par bartabas est
interprété par l'académie équestre de
versailles
elle présente son 21e opus c'est notre
histoire en raconte l'évolution de nos
chevaux là il ya des nouveaux chevaux
les fonderies qu'on voit au début sont
des chevaux qu'on a eu de tout petits à
un an et que là on met en spectacle
maintenant qu'ils ont eu huit ans donc
c'est vraiment l'évolution n'est le plus
sincère qu'on peut dans ce spectacle
avec ce qu'on vit au quotidien
cette année la promotion est
exclusivement féminine à l'académie les
écuyères ne font pas que de l'équitation
chorale danse ou encore escrime les
disciplines sont variés et permettent la
coordination et la cohésion de l'équipe
c'est une discipline qui les menait
c'est beaucoup de rigueur envers soi
même et en même temps du lâcher prise
donc c'est assez
il ya vraiment un équilibre à trouver
entre la technique est juste l'âme et
les sensations et donc ça à l'académie
comme on pratique d'autres disciplines
artistiques c'est très bien pour
développer ce côté sensibilité
le spectacle est chaque année améliorer
des tableaux sont ajoutés les chevaux et
écuyers se perfectionne au grand plaisir
de ses habitués toujours merveilleux de
venir ici on apprécie le spectacle de
chevaux sont tous magnifiques
il ya toujours des petits plus et des
nouvelles choses qu'on voit et
des différents chevaux et autres et là
on a vu qu'il y avait un cheval qui
était mort mais c'est extraordinaire le
travail qui est fait avec lui le
spectacle est présenté chaque week-end
tout au long de l'année
la commanderie à elancourt propose son
événement l'échappée belle dimanche 27
juin des ateliers des animations et des
spectacles seront proposés tout au long
de la journée
au programme également un marché de
producteurs locaux
dominique beinheim bonsoir vous êtes la
responsable de la commanderie
alors le thème de cet événement prendre
soin de soi et de la planète
alors pourquoi avoir choisi ce thème et
j'ajouterais de soi des autres et de la
planète
écoutez c'était déjà un événement qu'on
souhaitait mettre en place l'an dernier
je ne vous explique pas les raisons pour
lesquelles on n'a pas pu le faire et ça
ne semblait d'autant plus important de
lancer ça cette année donc de se
retrouver ensemble autour d'un moment
informatif participatif ludique et pour
dacourt prendre soin de soi
j'ai vu que des ateliers bien-être du
coup un sont proposés durant cette
journée donc dos le dos energia energo
santé est ce que vous pouvez me et que
vous m'expliquez juste derrière ce
concept
alors nous nous ce qui est important de
savoir aussi c'est que nous aurons des
collègues de saint quentin en yvelines
qui seront présents deux lors de cette
journée est entre autres due de
promotion de la santé et donc c'est
travail qui peine tout au long de
l'année
justement pour et santé et sport et donc
ils nous ont proposé d'accueillir cet
atelier qui va réunir et leurs disciples
pour retrouver des sensations dans le
corps et b se sentir mieux
tout simplement alors toujours à partir
atelier je veux qu'il y aurait un sonar
rup's qui pourra y participer tout le
monde en fait il suffit de s'inscrire
nous avons déjà accueilli ce sauna donc
il s'appelle un maintien en russie ont
déjà cuits dans le cadre du noël décalé
et ont fait c'est un pardon c'est un
tout petit sauna construit par benoît
race ou tout en bois
au feu de bois et avec cette petite
douche bien froide pour sortir des
tonneaux et fait au moins trois
personnes entrées dans cet espace
et comme on a des conditions sanitaires
très strictes adoptées en les créneaux
sont accordés soit des familles des
couples
voilà des gens qui se connaissent et a
donc à 14 heures
comment pardon je disais c'est vraiment
un sauna on y sera ici d'accord je
disais à 14h30 et 17h un spectacle
déambulatoire aura lieu et les visiteurs
pourront même participer
alors comment cela va se passer alors
c'est une compagnie qui s'appelle la
compagnie corossol qui nous a fait cette
proposition le spectacle qui s'appelle
biodiversité à ta santé et il s'agit
d'un quizz et est toujours l'idée
d'accueillir au mieux le lait le public
on a proposé que ce soit un spectacle
qui souhaitent ambulatoire et non pas un
endroit fixe tous les gens sont
statiques
donc c'est plutôt les quotidiens qui
vont aller interpeller faire des jeux au
fur et à mesure avec le public dans
l'espace de la commande d'accord merci
beaucoup
dominique venner d'avoir été notre
invité merci à vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pour finir cette page wazir je vous
propose une idée de sortie pour ce week
end
apprendre à reconnaître les arbres et
les plantes sauvages qui peuplent les
forêts yvelinoise l'association nature
et vous organise ce samedi 26 juin une
balade nature commentée autour de la
pièce d'eau des suisses à versailles
il sera également possible de découvrir
les multiples vertus de ces végétaux
la balade est uniquement sur réservation
plus d'informations sont à retrouver sur
le site sortir en yvelines et l'émission
elle continue avec eléonore pour parler
de l'actualité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
et à présent retour en 78 secondes sur
ce qui a fait l'actualité cette semaine
dans les yvelines avec astrid bergère et
grégory canal et la fête de la musique
mais aussi le premier jour de l'été à
voisins le bretonneux groupes locaux
associations de la ville et formations
se sont succédé sur une scène ouverte
aux jardins eugène fleuret
malheureusement la pluie s'est invitée
et à abréger la soirée et des orages se
sont abattus sur les yvelines ah oui des
dizaines de caves de particuliers de
commerces ont été inondés plus d'un
mètre pour certains aucun blessé n'est à
déplorer
près de 500 élèves des douze communes de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines se sont retrouvés à l'occasion
d'une journée olympique au golf national
ce mercredi 23 juin à l'occasion de
faire des découvertes sportives ou de
rencontrer des athlètes de haut niveau
une vingtaine d'étudiants de l'école
aisé au pari vélizy ont présenté leur
projet d'entrepreneuriat dans le cadre
d'un forum industriel
l'établissement est spécialisée dans la
formation d'ingénieurs pendant cette
journée ils ont rencontré des
représentants d'entreprises et des
institutionnels
enfin les élèves élan courtois de cm2
passante au collège ont pu profiter
d'une traditionnelle cérémonie organisée
par la commune coli des jauges oblige
cinq soirées ont été organisées entre le
14 et le 22 juin pour célébrer ses 400
élèves et discours applaudissements et
remise de cadeau pour fêter ce passage
importante dans une scolarité
[Musique]
et pour refermer ce 7,8 week-end ce
dimanche 27 juin ce sera le second tour
des élections régionales et
départementales
vous pouvez consulter l'ensemble des
propagandes électorales des candidats
pour les deux élections sur le site de
la préfecture des yvelines qui s'affiche
en bas de votre écran
l'ensemble de la rédaction de tv 78 sera
également sur le pont à pour suivre en
direct et pour vous faire vivre ces
élections dimanche soir sur le réseau
social twitter de tv 78 et lundi 28 juin
à 19h retrouvez notre édition spéciale
consacrée à ce double rendez vous
électoral
et voilà c'est déjà la fin de votre site
huit week-ends je vous souhaite un très
bon égaler une très belle soirée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]